so guys if you saw my interviews with
Sean Bean and Ali Larter for the new TNT
show legends you would have heard me
mentioned that I also got to interview
Morris Chestnut who also acts in the
show as well as a producer David Wilcock
these guys were really awesome and
really cool to talk to very cool very
laid-back very down-to-earth I had a
really good time talking to these guys I
hope you enjoy the interview legends
premieres on TNT August 13th legends
series premiere August 13th on TNT
all right guys so I'm sitting here with
Morris Chestnut and David Wilcock from
the new TNT show legends first off I saw
the show great work really good I like
this thank you personally for you Morris
what in the legend screenplay attracted
you to your character when I came onto
the show the pilot was already shot and
completed so I met with TNT and they
told me they had a great show called
legends and I watched the pilot and I
was just you know I loved all the actors
I loved the concept and the characters
and so I just wanted to be a part of it
did you find any similarities at all in
him to yourself that you gravitated
towards to the Tony rice yeah yeah
there's quite a few I think um he's a
you know he's a sports fan
he likes to bring levity to things he he
gets serious when he needs to there are
a lot of similarities very cool his
incredible intelligence incredibly
intelligent elegance and Mincy was not
enough he couldn't be a member now
because now you need something that's
pretty high rugged good looks yeah that
was an easy translation never scar you
up or anything like that one of the
things Howard said was that one of the
things he's attempting to do with the
show is to kind of set up certain pieces
anticipate certain things happening then
allow them to blow up and you know later
on in the show is that something you
guys are
thing to do is more of a slow burn type
of thing always I mean it's it's it we
do both you know we want our episodes to
be you know big and compelling and kind
of stand on their own merits but they
are part of a you no longer broader
story that we're telling over these 10
episodes and that that's always
something that that you know at the
beginning when we were talking about how
how this show we'd sort of Arc this show
out and and everything we sort of broke
it down into almost trilogies of where
Martin Odum would be in his journey and
part of that was was creating this
character of Tony Rice who would kind of
come into the story at first as somewhat
event an antagonist to Martin's journey
and then you know over a period of time
as it gets closer the truth really
begins to realize that Martin is a piece
of the puzzle not the the whole thing
and so you know they kind of come
together as as allies before it's all
said and done I personally feel that
makes for the most riveting type of
character character the changes a lot
that you're not sure what level he's on
is he a protagonist or an anti Huston
that's a really great character to play
yeah that's what I loved about it too
because that he does have that shift to
where he starts out in one place and he
ends up in another I can sing and once I
do start working with Martin Odum I
think that you know I just really enjoy
that in a chemistry and the storylines
that we have together any advice for
people who are trying to write TV pilots
right now because with the way TV has
become lately very groundbreaking a lot
more respect has been given the TV
lately than it used to be totally do you
think that writing TV pilots is becoming
harder or something that's actually more
sought-after oh no I think it's it's
more sought-after than than ever I think
that you know TV pilots give give
someone to an opportunity to really
showcase their storytelling skills
I think the demands of what you do in a
pilot you have to simultaneously be able
to you know create the world set the
characters off on their journey but also
really give a sense of kind of what the
show is and where it's going and that's
a it's harder than it looks
you know and
unlike a film or something where you're
resolving it as effectively resolving it
at the end you know you TV pilot has to
have some sort of sense of I think a
satisfying conclusion at least you know
in the micro but in the macro you see
that this world could just continue to
open up and that's it's conceptually I
think writing TV pilots is a lot harder
than then film I agree with you because
I personally tried it because films have
a simple three-act structure TV pilots
it's like you have characters you're
setting them up and then they can go
anywhere and even for an actor is that
kind of interesting to not exactly know
where your character could go it's one
of those things to where it's definitely
interesting as an actor the only part
about it that I like is that I do get to
pick up the script each week and not
know right but then as an actor the part
the aspect of it that I don't like about
is that we can't like to know where
we're going so we kind of plant the
seeds and kind of subtly do things that
would you know lead to the direction
that we're going so that's the hard part
is like oh man if I know that my
character was gonna do this I would have
made this choice last episode when this
happens yeah but but that's exactly why
we wouldn't tell you because you know I
don't want you to play the ending I
don't want you to play the you know play
the reveal so that was I mean that was
very much a well it was it was kind of a
combo it was the fact that we didn't
really have enough time you know when I
Jimbo
when I came into this and and my partner
Josh pate came into this you know we
were pretty we only had about six or
seven weeks to to really get the show on
its feet and write all these episodes
and everything so maybe a couple times I
didn't know where we were going I did
that and I do understand it doesn't make
it I think it does make it more
interesting going wrong you know
it would for me personally - I like that
for you you're basically like a viewer
without a doubt is there something that
you particularly really look for in a
director how do you like to have that
relationship between a director and an
actor well it's a lot different in
chosen it is in film with a film you
start from the beginning you have your
her CIL's with the director and you you
know you archive everything then you
kind of get on the same page and in film
and TV it's you know they come in one
they come in on Episode five and they
kind of sum up don't they don't know
what happened in Episode two and three I
mean to put a more positive spin on it
is is what I would say is we always
talked about you know relying on on you
and Sean and Steve and Allie and Tina
and amber to really be sort of the the
the keeper of your own character right
and so so I knew that that you know
writing a scene where yeah I knew you
would know sort of tonally where you
would live in that scene right back.that
that you knew your character and and
except we had conversations along the
way there was a surprise to me I you
know we had a producer director Brad
Turner who was it was amazing and he did
that and over as all that yes but but
the other thing that I think is really
interesting is our directors would you
know I want them to capture a sort of
the tone and style of the show and and
part of that is I know they don't have
to they don't have to sort of hold yeah
well guys it was really nice to meet you
thanks very much
keep me alive the truth
to destroy me Legends series premiere
Wednesday August 13 to 9:00 on TNT so
hopefully now you guys have seen all of
my interviews that I was able to conduct
for the new TNT show legends I had such
a great time in LA it really was a
life-changing experience for me I got to
meet a lot of really cool people
legends premieres on TNT August 13th I
hope you guys check out the show and as
always thank you so much for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right here and get stockman eyes
[Music]